We will now look at an example of mHealth that the FDA does regulate.
As shown here, a live course Kardia mobile device detects the electrocardiogram or
ECG heart trace and sends it to
the company's smartphone app using
inaudible ultrasonic signals after requesting access to the microphone.
The company says this communications approach reduces
battery consumption by around 92% versus Bluetooth,
and provides much higher data resolution.
However, it does require the device to be no more than a foot away from the phone.
A number of journal articles report on success in using
the AliveCor device and other competing devices to screen for atrial fibrillation,
the most common cardiac arrhythmia and one that can lead to
strokes if the condition is not identified and properly treated.
The company says it is working on an ECG band device for Apple's watch.